So, to summarize this, we brought together concepts of convolution and
correlation, specifically cross-correlation, to compute image gradience,
use that to compute image edges, we talked about how smoothing, is important
in computing gradience, and I showed four different ways of actually using,
a specific type of kernel and a pipeline to compute edges from images.
Next, we're going to take a little bit of a different turn in our work, so
far, we've been talking a lot about images, we're going to go back and
now talk about cameras, optics, and lenses, this will allow us to
start thinking about the computation photography pipeline, and
a little bit more carefully, and then we'll actually return back to edges and
its detection, as we get into whole concept of feature matching.
We'll also be looking at very ideal ways we can actually look at an image not
just at its own scale of resolution but also multiple resolutions of the image.
More exciting stuff is on the way.